North America correspondent for Al
Jazeera Arabic he joins us from close to
the presidential Palace in the Brazilian
Capital Hassan says Security Forces say
they've now regained control of these
government buildings tell us where you
are now and what's happening there
yeah Darren we are now at the entrance
of the presidential palace here in the
capital of Brazil Brasilia where yeah
the security forces regained uh control
and closed the area uh completely to
control this area but we can see uh the
damage that happened here in the
presidential Palace in Brasilia these
are exclusive images
from the presidential Palace that is
called here El planeto and this is the
uh the place where the president of
Brazil
control uh the the the the government
where he meet with the ministers in this
Palace and here he was
announced as a president at this place
exactly where we are we can see the
damage that happened after invading this
Palace by the
supporters of the former president jair
bolsonaro we can see the the damage a
lot of damage and the security forces
are now uh controlling the palace they
are checking the on the damage that
happened here we can see also uh here
the the security uh officers the the
federal police
exactly and especially they are here now
controlling the capital of Brazil after
announcing
a special and uh extraordinary orders
from the president of Brazil Lula da
Silva ordering the federal police and
the federal institutions to control the
security and the capital now here also
we can see the Supreme Court Earth where
also it was invaded during the day by
the supporters of jair bolsonaro it was
also damaged we saw the the damage the
the the broken glass uh the the broken
windows and the security forces also
regained the power now uh the the the
square here that is called the three
power square and the middle of the uh
capital of Brazil is a empty completely
from any uh of the supporters of Jerry
bolsonaro
and after the uh after putting and
capturing 200 of these supporters of
these Invaders that are called as uh uh
people that they try to do a cope here
in Brazil by the minister of security
and Justice uh of of Brazil and he said
and announced that the government will
start the investigations they already
started the investigations to know who
supported and who uh helped and the and
this
Invasion that happened in the capital of
Brazil for the first time in the history
of uh of Brazil uh since the regaining
the uh the Democracy in Brazil since the
80s
we didn't see any of these uh images uh
Happening Here in the capital of Brazil
all right Hassan Mahmoud Al Jazeera
arabics North America correspondent
they're live for us there from the
Brazilian Capital Hassan thank you